foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
I'm Piers Morgan I'm censored tonight
Civil War on the conservative party
again over Boris Johnson again Nadine
Doris joined him in sensationally
quitting as an MP this weekend
exclusively she'll tell me why
former president Donald Trump is braced
his second arrest in three months facing
federal charges over the hoarding of
classified documents which even contain
nuclear secrets like Boris he says it's
all a Witch Hunt but how much trouble is
he now in plus half of the England
ladies angling team quits in protest
over a trans athlete the latest gender
Scandal to engulf women's sport
Parliament today held a major debate on
whether the words man or woman mean
biological sex the woman behind it join
me live
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored well
good evening Veranda welcome to Piers
Morgan on censor Boris Johnson and
Donald Trump are the big beast of
political bull but these two blonde
Bombshells are Bluster in our face of
ferocious fight for their political
lives they've both been unraveled by The
Reckless breaking of laws I clearly
think apply to everyone but themselves
and they're both going down and a tail
spin of temper tantrums which attempt to
shift the blame to everybody but
themselves Trump now faces his second
arrest in three months on federal
charges that he hardly classifies
documents at his Florida estate even
piling them up in a shower his response
I'm the victim it's all a Witch Hunt
Boris Johnson he's a hoax the whole
thing is a hoax just like Russia Russia
Russia just like the fake dossier was a
hoax I'm an innocent man I did nothing
wrong and we will fight this out just
like we've been fighting for seven years
Boris Johnson's stunning resignation
from Parliament on Friday night was
accompanied by a self-pity in tirade
that could have been written by Trump
himself
facing sanctions from the Privileges
committee which has been investigating
whether he lied to MPS over his law
breaking lockdown parties in Downing
Street Johnson's crying conspiracy he
called it a Witch Hunt an attempt to
subvert brexit and democracy by a
kangaroo court
there's something really to do with
brexit it's not a kangaroo court four of
its seven members are brexit supporting
conservatives they spent almost a year
investigating it's just the same old
populist Playbook deny it happened claim
it's a Witch Hunt when all else fails so
the whole system is poisoned against
them
Italy's former Premier Silvio Berlusconi
who has died was not a big beast of
Bluster another extraordinarily
charismatic leader but he used the very
same tactics denouncing criminal charges
against him as a political Vendetta a
Witch Hunt and working to undermine
public trust in the very institutions
responsible for delivering Justice
well Boris Johnson resigned just hours
after down the street published his
resignation on his list without the
names and some of his key supporters two
of them are Dean Doris and Nigel Adams
have joined him in quitting Parliament
now prime minister Rishi sunak has
declared war by accusing Boris of asking
him to intervene presumably to get even
more of his cronies on the list
Boris Johnson asked me to do something
that I wasn't prepared to do because I
didn't think it was right that was to
you know either overrule the holak
committee or to make promises with
people now I I wasn't prepared to do
that as I said I didn't think it was
right and if people don't like that then
tough
well Boris says rishi's talking rubbish
but as soon as I could tell him the
truth and the public can judge which of
them as a better relationship with the
truth is yet another attempt by Boris to
subvert the rules to get what he wants
plenty of Johnson's allies were given
honors his hairdresser becomes an
officer of the British Empire a 29 year
old former Advisor Charlotte Owen
becomes a life peer somebody no one's
ever heard of permanently a noble by
prime minister who left office in our
parliament in shame and disgrace and
north of the Border another big beast of
British politics Nicholas sturgeon is
refusing to step aside from a Scottish
nationalist National party that she once
LED she suspended S P members for much
less serious things than the police
investigation into party finances that
she's now embroiled in yesterday she was
arrested and quizzed by police for
nearly eight hours but she remains in
the party once again one rule for you
another for them but maybe the Golden
Age of big beasts and their bull might
just be coming to an end well joining me
in the is the soon to be former
conservative MP for me
I wouldn't have expected to agree with
much of that no none of it actually so
let's take that as read
um all right this is the first interview
you've given so this all blew up so
let's just cut to the quick here when
Rishi sunak the British prime minister
says that Boris Johnson tried to get him
to effectively circumnavigate the rules
about the honors including yours
is he telling the truth
so he's using something which I called
think they're called sophistry which is
using a language and words in order to
deceive what Boris Johnson actually
asked him to do was to ask Colac to do
the re-betting which required to be done
NPS now can I just explain why that's
important so every six months a
re-betting has took place I'll tell you
what I'll tell you what it's made this
easy for the viewers okay who aren't up
to speed on all the nuances let's go
back to the beginning yeah Boris Johnson
tells you when that he's intending to
make you a baroness when does he have
that first oh that was ages ago that was
back in the Autumn sometime it was a
private conversation you're not allowed
to talk about it afterwards there's a
private conversation to say that I'd
been put on his resignation honors list
to be a baroness yeah that's what it is
when you go into the Lords okay and what
was your reaction to that how did you
feel about that
it was quite emotional actually because
I never you know I've always revered the
House of Lords I think it's actually a
place where all I know a lot of people
criticize it but and make fun of it
almost but it's a place where all the
heavy lifting of the scrutiny of bills
actually takes place the commons has
become this like this set piece theater
for prime ministers questions and and
for other big pieces but actually we're
all the heavy lifting where the where
it's stuck full of people with expertise
and wisdom and knowledge it's the laws
and so it's a kind of place you look at
I know there are a lot of old useless
duffers there as well
there may possibly be but I couldn't
comment but but there's also a lot of
like really serious heavy lifting goes
on there and it is a place that you know
God like for me from my background no
one would ever have dreamed that someone
from my background could get with people
who don't know your background why do
you say that so I was born in a place
called Breck Road in Liverpool which I
think is probably classified as one of
the forest streets in the country not
just in Liverpool one of the poorest
Wards and you know it was most of my
life you know the first almost 30 years
of my life were very tough it was you
know financially very very hard I
literally it sounds like something over
Dickens novel but I literally had to
borrow shoes to go to school I literally
know what hunger pains feel like and you
know I've been a long time ago I was
born in 57 the 60s went great for you
know in the early 70s for surviving and
there wasn't a benefit system or you
know the safety net that there is today
for people so it was pretty tough and to
think that you know I didn't even know
what a university was I didn't know that
universities even existed it was it was
just something that the House of Lords I
wouldn't have known if you'd asked me a
21 you know the House of Lords keep them
knowing what it was so to be told that
you're being put on a list to be
nominated to go into the House of Lords
it's just like it's unbelievable and for
me it's so important because now I did
this a lot when I was sexual estate in
dcms it was all about making sure that
ladders were put down into those
backgrounds to give people opportunities
to work in the arts and culture because
they are because they don't now because
the kind of people who do work in arts
and culture do those who went to
independent school or you know whose
dad's a producer or whatever so for me
it was kind of that's the next stage you
know if I go into the Lords it actually
sends a signal to other people doesn't
matter where you come from doesn't
matter what you're born to doesn't
matter how poor you are if you if you
you can get there you know I call it the
class stealing or the class ceiling
where I come from I wanted to break that
ceiling okay so it means a lot to you
yeah clearly I can tell that right means
a lot to you but I would imagine serving
your constituents as a member of
parliament also means a lot to you yeah
I mean
the great honors anyone can have in this
country yeah to be an elected official
representing your constituents so that
then obviously be an inevitable question
to come but from that moment Boris
Johnson
tells you that's his intention
do you just assume it's going to happen
so what I thought was I expected someone
to contact me and talk to me I thought
it might be holak who's the House of
Lords what's the normal procedure so
well there is this is why I couldn't
there's no normal procedure I couldn't
find this out the normal procedure I've
discovered is that whole act who is
holak House of Lords appointment
commission right so they and they had
the right to approve or discipline no
they have no right to approve or
disapprove so this rhetoric which has
been coming out of Downey street is that
the house of laws did not approve it
it's absolutely nonsense they don't have
that it's not their mandate so boss's
list goes into number 10 number 10 hand
it over to holak who act do the vetting
that's police checks and hmrc checks
then they hand that list back to number
10 number 10 then hand that list over to
the king so what happened was holak said
to number 10
this MP needs to pick a public
announcement that she will stand down
within six months of being put back to
you on this list nobody from number 10
communicated that to me
Boris found out about this and had a
meeting with Rishi last week
six months had elapsed since the betting
had been done why Downing Street waited
six months I have no idea six months
elapsed Boris said to British Union you
just need to ask for the re-veting which
would take a matter of days Rishi used
very weasel words he said to Boris
Johnson and that's that's the only thing
Boris asked him to do he said to Boris
whatever list holak sent back to me I
will sign off both left that meeting
with the impression but James Forsyth
who is zoonat's political secretary was
going to ask for the re-veting for the
list to come forward and then Rishi to
sign it off but of course Rishi was
using those words because he knew a
situation had been engineered I.E the
information her like again had not been
not been communicated to me and
therefore my name would not be on the
list because I hadn't done what her like
asked number 10 to ask me to do because
nobody had asked me to do it I hope like
I've let it be known that they did not
support some of the people that they
couldn't because they couldn't support
the people had been put forward because
we hadn't done what had been asked
that's the only reason that they
wouldn't support it it wasn't the
failure of any of the vetting no no no
absolutely not no right so there were
six people on this so This sounds like a
sort of murder mystery plot that you'd
have at a friend's dinner party who
who's the murderer here who has stopped
you Nadine Doris from joining the house
of laws do you believe the prime
minister
you think he personally intervened
um well he so very cleverly of course
not his political secretary James
Forsyth would do the the heavy lifting
the the the not passing the message on
not doing what hola asked it was James
Forsyth but obviously James boss Knight
works but I mean Jose is Rich she's not
his best friend he was his best manager
yeah but you're saying that number 10
directly intervened to stop you what
they did join in miles of laws what they
did that's what you're saying that right
what they did was not pass on the
information from holak which was
she has to announce that she will stand
down with insects because you cannot be
an MP and sit in the house you can't be
two in two houses you can't be in two
ledges such as that did you not know
that rule yes they knew but what we'd
been told via back channels was that
don't cause by-election there will be a
solution something's going to be found
that's what I was being told by it the
cabinet secretary and back channels so
that's my cabinet secretary said to you
is all going to be fine the the cabinet
secretary came up with a plan originally
with another cabinet secretary that
there would be a system that was put in
place Ruth Davidson an asterisk system
which meant we could go on the list and
we would stay there until a general
election we found out that suddenly that
wasn't allowed and then that's when
things that's when I began to get
suspicious started asking questions was
met with a wall of silence and then
Boris Johnson also began to think
something's not quite right here that's
why he asked the meetings especially
soon like number 10 I know why they did
this they did this because they wanted
to avoid a by-election if they'd worked
with me we could have had this
by-election a time which was suitable to
them maybe after the Autumn statements
come out when hopefully there'll be some
good news we've got to work together but
instead did did Rishi soon lie to Boris
did Boris lie did was she soon at lie to
Boris Johnson in their meeting so what
I've said to you is you use sophistry
some very clever words I will sign off
whatever list holak give to me knowing
full well that my name was not a mine
and other names were not on that list
because they had engineered that those
names were not on that list by not
informing us the request made by ho Lac
to number 10 informing us what we needed
are you sure Boris Johnson didn't take
you off that list
100 it wouldn't be the first time he's I
want these fifth people no I don't think
that's true well it is true well I don't
believe it is my I can only speak is my
experience of rice Johnson those I know
and it's it's a very positive you're
certain that he wouldn't have taken you
off absolutely certain
absolutely same
Boris I mean for one of a bit of race
threw his toys out of the pram after all
this happened some say you did too you
appeared on talk TV no I didn't well I'm
going to throw you a clip from talk TV
this is before the news breaks this is
what you said to Mike Graham
the last thing I would want to do would
be to cause a by-election something
significant did happen to change my mind
and and I did do and I think it's for
the best
and literally hours later you quit and
provoked because I think significant did
happen and that there are two
significant things that happened to the
first was
um that I realized by a number of
conversations what had happened and the
reason why I realized what was happened
was
a phone call was made to Simon case on
Thursday evening and he was told no to
an aid at boris's office he was told no
everything's fine her name's on the list
I phoned Boris phoned the next morning
iPhone the next morning we were told I
spoke to the chief whip shortly actually
so Thursday the cabinet secretary
confirms your name with an aide from
boris's office so what could have
happened I'm just about to tell you okay
so um I spoke to the chief whip in the
morning and he said no everything's fine
on Friday morning the list was announced
at four o'clock on Friday afternoon I
suppose the chief whip on Friday morning
he said no no everything's fine
everything's fine he said let me let me
go make some inquiries and I'll get back
to you he got back to me 13 minutes
before the less was published and said
actually you're not on the list
30 minutes and you found out from a
journalist I found out from Steve swim
from the times on Thursday night and I
didn't believe him I thought he was
lying to me and I was crossed with him I
said Steve why are you doing this you
know I thought to myself why isn't he
just finding out the evidence for this
story properly someone is doing this do
you think you think the motivation for
what Downing Street you believe did in
stopping you uh getting this honor is
that they didn't want to trigger a
by-election which is pretty ironic given
is actually a collection three
by-elections it's pretty stupid actually
not ironic it was pretty stupid if they
thought they were being clever and
avoiding by electricity by thinking that
they could play well of course they're
going to deny it are they lying they are
not telling the truth so they're lying
no they're not tying the shoes they're
not telling the truth but the prime
ministers there were two points then
promises are going to bring Integrity
back to public life he's certainly not
doing that he's certainly not doing that
and you know do you believe Richard
sunak is lying about it so there are
three points there are three issues that
number two have lied on they've lied on
the fact that they denied the meeting
with Boris Johnson even took place to be
and they denied a journalist and then
accepted they had to acknowledge the
meeting did take place then they lied
and said that we were on the list and
everything was absolutely fine they gave
the impression to Boris Johnson that
they were going to ask for the
re-betting and that my name and others
would be on the list and it would be
signed off their lies were told in a in
a number of ways and what I don't
understand is the stupidity of it and
I've written about this in my column on
The Daily Mouse where I put a timeline
down about what actually happened what I
don't understand is the stupidity of
this and the Psycho Drama creation of it
and the one point I would make is you
know there were lots of criticisms about
what happened under virus John and about
the dramas that I compared to number 10
well here's another one under Rishi
sunak and the entire time that the
dramas were occurring at number 10 while
Rishi sunak was number two working teeth
cheek by Gile with let me ask you number
one let me ask you know why the point
should somebody who's been prime
minister and has had to be forced out of
office in disgrace you may or may not
agree with why but that was the reality
should they be entitled to have a
resignation on us this many people I'm
one of them think that any prime
minister who has to quit in dishonorable
circumstances should abrogate the right
to have analysis I'm not passing
judgment on you getting one or any
others right I'm just saying I don't
think that that is good for the system
so you know if there had been a shred of
evidence
to justify the findings of the
provisions Committee Against Boris
Johnson if they had what if they had
well there is more than a trade no there
isn't peers there is not a shred of
evidence so a privileges committee hang
on which has seven people on it four of
whom are euroskeptic brexit supporting
conservatives you're saying they set out
to destroy Boris Johnson the Prime
Minister who won a big majority and
delivered brexit you think that that's a
realistic scenario no I think that's a
very simplistic scenario that you've
presented because it's a fact because
when it Well it Well it isn't actually
because what takes place is that that
committee it's under scrutiny under a
huge amount of public scrutiny there are
many events that have taken place that
have been wrong with that committee for
example the submissions by Sue gray who
we just happen to know was working with
labor at the time here we just happened
to know employed at QC foreign
the Privileges committee made the
conclusions this made which clearly when
Boris read them he decided was so bad he
had to quit immediately peers I regard
the police as a higher authority they
find it they find him and Rishi sooner
she soon actually be driven out of
parliament because he was fined as well
well have you read this report by the
Privileges committee no I haven't right
so you know what this says so you're
convinced us to stitch up you haven't
read it I know the facts about the facts
that they're working on no you know what
Boris told you if you're saying what
Boris says in the word fact are two
different things a lot of the time well
again we are never going to agree on
that but if well you think he's always
tells the truth if Boris Johnson has
been driven out of parliament for having
Saturday's desk and not eating a piece
of cake when people he was working with
all day in the same offices came into
that room to wish him happy birthday if
you think that is the basis for driving
him out of office I think he's more than
that I think it's more than there were
the karaoke parties on the night before
no he wasn't it's his home no it's not
his home he was in checkers it's his
home no Piers well so again that's
correct a point there it's Rishi who
lives above number 10. Boris lived above
number 11 next door it was rishi's home
it's Bryce's office during the day but
it was actually rishi's home are you
actually going to quit as an MP yeah
I've resigned there's no way back some
people think you may you may change your
mind that you were being a bit
hot-headed no so you never formally
resigned you haven't let me explain to
you the significant thing that happened
to change my mind to make me oh God it
was the sheer audacity of the chief whip
thinking but at my age after having
worked in Parliament for 21 years
serving 18 years on the back benches
having been a minister during covered in
health having been a secretary of state
that he could dangle out me some kind of
stick and carrot like be a good girl and
we'll make sure something's sorted for
you in the future which is basically
what he was saying to me that for me at
that moment was what made me change my
mind and made me make my decision too
how upset are you at now not getting
this honor you assumed you were going to
get not joining the House of Lords not
being baroness at the end of all this
Julie what I'm broken-hearted not just
for me but for everybody who comes from
a background like mine
who in today's world don't have the
ability to climb ladders that they used
to have years ago who who struggled to
Aspire because they feel that it just
isn't worth being aspirational it isn't
worth working hard because they see
others from different backgrounds who
take the spoils and it kind of breaks my
heart because that that's what this
story is this story is about a girl from
Breck Road and Liverpool who worked
every day of her life since she was 14
years old had something offered to her
for that people from that background
don't get offered removed by two
privileged Posh boys who went to win
Winchester and Oxford and taken away
duplicity and crawly because they have
known for months that it wasn't the case
and yet they let me and they let Boris
Johnson continue to believe that was the
case it was upsetting and It's upsetting
for everybody who thinks that one day
they could be that person because you
know what if you come up against someone
like Rishi sunak and James Forsyth from
privileged backgrounds who have it all
very easily given to them on a plate
you're in trouble you won't make it
because they can do whatever they want
to stop it there are a lot of people
there are a lot of people who would say
exactly same about your mate Boris that
you won't get anyone who's been more
privileged than him or he went to Eaton
who has glided effortlessly through life
people say on the bones of his backside
most of his life you had no money he's
always been on the bones of his backside
most of his life
scholarship he is you cannot make that
comparison here's what's about Boris I
like him personally always have done
right but I think the way he has run the
country has been a disgrace and that's
why he's got his comeuppance and when
this report comes out maybe even as soon
as tomorrow you will read it and you
might be surprised about what they
Unearthed it wasn't a Witch Hunt it
wasn't a stitch up why would it be four
of the seven on the committee
distinguished conservatives who voted
for brexit I'll tell you why it would be
because one of the main contributors
that report was Sue gray who's now gone
to work for Kirsten and who wants Boris
gone out of Westminster more than Rishi
sunak kirst armor does we'll never agree
well that okay final question
you handing him a by-election which they
will now probably gang up with the lib
Dems to win yeah how does that help your
party
my party isn't helping itself no but why
are you knifing the party I'm not knife
in the party in a way you are no players
I think you come to a point in life when
you have when you have to stop when you
can't just be pushed around when you
can't allow people to bully you as I've
just been bullied by number 10 you can't
allow that to happen you have to stand
up for yourself and that's what I did
it's a painful decision I didn't know
when I said to Mike in the morning I did
not want to cause a by-election I've
Loved serving it's been a great fun of
my life to serve mid babisha for 18
years leaving it in the lurch like this
to go to this by-election was not what I
wanted you said a moment ago about what
a what an honor it is when I my majority
was 24 600 when those people 38 000
people went out and voted for me the
last election those people went out and
put their cross next to my name that is
the biggest and they'll all be watching
anyone and they'll be watching this
thinking well why have you abandoned
this I think they'll understand yeah I
think they'll understand and I think
they'll think we wouldn't let anyone do
that to us either
Nadine thank you for coming in I
appreciate it
on since the next tonight Donald Trump
has arrived in Florida to have a court
appearance tomorrow and charges of
mishandling documents is Trump toast
we'll debate that next
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
I get the idea that you people think
that some politicians deliberately
mislead others isn't it shocking yeah
they're coming from the United States
you could never imagine such a thing
never never you know the United States
we've got nothing like that yeah uh
Kevin it was actually a very interesting
interview in many ways who do we believe
here yeah Nadine dory's clearly feels
let down I think she's been LED down by
Boris Johnson as well as Rishi sunak
Rishi sunak didn't want a by-election so
he didn't want to have a peerage that
would trigger it but I think Boris
Johnson's misled her because he wanted
soon act to overrule the House of Lords
committee could it be internal number 10
skullduggery as she suggests to make
sure that her name and several others
got removed to avoid any potential for a
violation I mean we've seen worse things
happening oh yeah I think I think at
least Boris yeah I think that's been a
factor because eight names were removed
uh where's Paul dagger the
editor-in-chief of the daily daily mail
others weren't on it I've known this to
happen before but at the same time Boris
Johnson is over promised by trying to
give 15 peer edges you were never going
to get that I mean as to my problem with
all this I don't think a Dishonored
prime minister who's left in disgrace
should be allowed to give any honors to
anybody I mean if you start from Central
premise I actually felt quite sorry from
Nadine that when she tells the story of
her own life and what it actually would
have meant to become a baroness I mean
it's quite moving on a human level right
I got it she's clearly very upset about
this I get that I think but on the other
hand I don't think any of them should
have got honors at the hands of Boris
Johnson after everything he did well the
thing is if we disqualify what we
consider you know a dishonest uh prime
minister from being able to hand out
these privileges then you you can call
other Prime Ministers into question I do
think it caused the entire analyst
system into question I do think we
should scrap it because at this point
it's just ridiculous I I agree scrub it
start again but let's remember Tony
Bland Gordon Brown as far as I can
remember didn't have resignation on his
list and there was a big round over
Johnson's wait until we have Liz trusses
39 days
at Liz truss after 44 days was it yeah
49 in all I think right in office gets
to give an honor out in her name mockery
of the system
like Awards of Lifetime law making to
our cronies I think there's four being
promised tag
she's going to make some news with some
of that stuff particularly some of the
things she said about Richie sunac I
mean yeah this is not going to go away
this is the Tory party ripping yourself
apart the question is can they basically
carve off this element the Boris and his
acolyte element to one side and Power on
perhaps they can yeah well that's a
strategy but you've got three
by-elections they're all going to be
tricky yeah there we are it's just not
going to go away they'll probably lose
them all but they will definitely lose
them all but they have enough of them I
want to bring in the magician yeah just
by Magic we're now going to turn to your
country because we're going to make
ourselves feel better by talking about
Donald Trump exactly
exactly we may have
a person running for president from
prison well by the way you know the
craziest thing about that he's allowed I
don't know I know we already have that
happen until the U.S Constitution not
only can Donald Trump run for president
if he's convicted of a federal crime of
the ones he's been accused of uh but
actually he could be imprisoned and
still serve as president service
president yes can you imagine it this is
the greatest cell that any president has
ever ever been incarcerated this is the
greatest I am the greatest felon in the
history of the White House I come to you
tonight imagine if it's a serious affair
right I come to you tonight from cell
four five six
this may all sound ridiculous this could
happen so let's bring in an expert
Donald Trump's former lawyer Alan
dershowitz one of the smartest legal
brains I've probably ever encountered
Alan make some sense of all this we're
sitting here across the pond in the
United Kingdom and it seems to us
utterly insane that somebody can now be
indicted on one case involving your
house payments to a porn star now
indicted federally on what appeared to
be far more serious charges under the
Espionage Act involving classified
documents is he's heard on tape boasting
are not Declassified put some some some
meat on this rumor mill bone about all
this where is Donald Trump now where is
he leaving
the first case is a joke the New York
case uh they made up uh facts they made
up law he won't be convicted and he
shouldn't be convicted the second case
the federal case much more serious they
have his own words and the words of his
lawyers making incriminating statements
it is certainly possible he could be
convicted the Constitution does not as
you say preclude him from running uh as
a an indicted or even convicted or even
imprisoned person I doubt he'll be
imprisoned but it's certainly possible
we have a strange situation here we have
a situation where Trump was targeted
perhaps even illegally they went after
him in order to try to focus on him and
him alone but they succeeded as the
result of unlawful actions of targeting
him
with his own cooperation they came up
with evidence on tape that may very well
be enough to convict him now is it okay
to convict somebody if you've improperly
targeted him but the targeting resulted
in evidence of real crime for example if
this were in the South If This Were a
racist prosecutor in the 1930s who said
I'm only going to investigate crimes
committed by black people not white
people and he investigated and found the
crime committed by a black person would
we say it's okay to prosecute and maybe
now this is different this isn't race
this is politics and politics is
different but there are troubling
aspects of this case they've used the
words of his own lawyer against him the
judges ruled that he violated the lawyer
client privilege it's a complicated case
if I was still teaching at Harvard as I
was from 50 years I'd be using this as a
case study
hold with this we're gonna take a short
commercial your brake pen I can see you
chomping at the bit you will be allowed
to come off that bit okay and give me
your view after the break
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
McGuire the brilliant magician and
probably the more handsome half of Ben
and tell evangelit he would say that I
wouldn't say that in front of Taylor
obviously uh they're performing at the
house of the Apollo in London from
tomorrow until the until Sunday through
so it's a brilliant show these guys are
the best the best magicians in the world
so go let's go see that gives us a treat
and Industrials are still with us so Pat
you were chomping at a bit that are
getting on what Alan was saying why I
did not teach at Harvard I am not a
lawyer but I am a liar and I am a
magician I mean that's what we do and it
sounded to me and what didn't I
understand here uh Mr distribution
um it sure seemed like you were saying
yeah he was doing stuff wrong but they
were trying to catch him as soon as you
become president as soon as you become
any sort of public figure everybody's
trying to bust you all the time and
that's actually okay let's bring Alan
back in that's a very good point Donald
Trump is not a regular not a regular
person he's a he's a very controversial
president who's already been indicted uh
by New York State on another issue he's
facing other huge legal issues involving
January the sixth the Riots of the
capital involving the phone call uh to
Georgia and so on so this is a guy
already smothered in legal Jeopardy why
shouldn't they be going hard after him
well that's exactly why I wrote my book
Shameless plug that is the most
Shameless
you should do I can pull rabbits out of
a hat I wrote a whole book on why there
has been a campaign to get Donald Trump
look I'm not a trump supporter I voted
against him twice I have a
constitutional right to vote against him
the third time and I intend to but I
don't want a bunch of prosecutors to
prevent Americans from voting for him or
against him well they shouldn't be
compared to he shouldn't be compared to
every ordinary person but he should be
compared to Hillary Clinton Joe Biden
vice president Pence Sandy Berger others
who have allegedly committed comparable
crimes and if what we're seeing is an
attempt to Target him uniquely by the
Democratic administration because he is
the chief Republican who's going to be
running against the incumbent Democrat
it better be a very strong case but he's
knocking
maybe I mean I got to say I gotta say I
saw Maggie Haberman from The New York
Times say this was the most compelling
indictment she'd think she's ever read
she also said that she also said similar
things about the New York case and yeah
William ball William Barr he's former
Attorney General he said the same thing
I I think this is a strong case the
question is it a strong enough case I
had a piece in the Wall Street Journal
today is it a strong enough case to
Warrant going after a man who's running
for president remember we're gonna have
to have a trial the trial will be a year
from now right in the beginning of the
conventions uh will he be tried during
the election after the election it has
to meet a very high standard I call it
the Nixon standard the Nixon standard is
he destroyed evidence he bribed
Witnesses the evidence was so clear that
the people who wanted him out of office
were his fellow Republicans we haven't
seen that okay
as always we about we all bow to your
expert legal brain because
we appreciate it and I wanted to
slightly change gear to uh we'll say
goodbye to Adam thank you very much I
just want to bring in the issue of
Nicholas sturge the recently departed
first finish for Scotland Esther I mean
this is a shattering blow yeah another
British political leader who spent eight
hours with the police at the weekend
under arrest over this financial
skullduggery which allegedly also
involves her husband who was the CEO of
the party I mean what is going on here I
mean hers her situation I think is
actually worse because she was she's
married to the man right there's no way
you can tell me in the sort of the
decade or so that they were well all
this was six hundred thousand pounds has
just disappeared exactly you can't say
that she didn't know anything and I
think the idea that she somehow still
has a place in the party is completely
ludicrous to me I can't believe she has
she got she made a lot of people for
lesser offenses in my opinion stepped
Down Kevin yeah she has to be suspended
sure yeah she does but of course her
success
is the continuity sturgeon candidate for
first minister and he's not applied the
rules she was applying to others when
msps were suspended the downfall of
Nicholas sturgeon she protests her
innocence is the fastest most dramatic I
can remember my time Kevin politically
this is also a massive boost for Kia
stama because all this stuff the Taurean
fighting the downfall of the SMP right
you put it all together this is
Christmas come early for Kirsten oh it
is all the cards are falling uh in his
favor and I I didn't think labor were in
with a chance of winning with a
substantial majority I'm now having to
wonder if they could be because in
Scotland it is such a big boost for
labor you get to 12 or 12 or 20 20 seats
he's worth a couple of accounts on the
National Pool I want to bring in you to
talk specifically about UFOs and aliens
in Las Vegas all right I'm only half
joking a whistleblower has come forward
called David Gray she's an Air Force
veteran claims he's viewed evidence of a
UFO crash retrieval program secretly run
by the US apparently a lot of this
stuff's been spotted around Nevada where
you have obviously before what do you
make of this well you know we have to
remember that the you in UFO is
unidentified it is not alien uh there's
a there's a big difference I mean there
are things unidentified in my
refrigerator that doesn't mean they're
of aliens there's an alien things in
your refrigerator I just I mean I I
don't understand that at all the science
really says that just in terms of
distances are you saying you can move
um hundreds of millions of light years
and then you crash in the desert I mean
what is it likely that we're the only
people in the entire galaxy no it's
barely the only created it's very very
unlikely but it's also very unlikely we
could ever find out you know there's uh
if you're talking about a hundred
thousand millions of light years
um you can't get the message out and
back at the same time also we are also
assuming that life on another planet
would want to talk to us yeah there's a
lot of us I would imagine it was a big
bull yeah
they do if they do come now why don't we
just give them Boris Johnson and Donald
Trump we've thought about this and as a
planet this is our offering right all
right take them and off you go it's 100
million light years away uh guys thank
you all very much lovely to see you it's
great to see you and have a brilliant
few a few dates that happens it is a
fantastic show they are the best
magicians of the world go see them uh
hamsters Apollo until Sunday starting
tomorrow uh if there are anything is
there maybe there aren't going to see
thanks Pat and says the next MP stage
and major debate on whether man or woman
should be legally defined by biological
sex the woman behind him tell me why
next
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
over the honors list and Ricky Gervais
receives death threats over his
controversial jokes so he's had to
increase security at his gigs and prince
Andrew is apparently refusing to leave
his Windsor home fearing if he does
he'll be kicked out that's all at nine
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to Facebook nonsense and
half of England ladies angling team has
quit in protest after a trans woman was
selected to join the squad for a major
competition the trans angler a former
rugby player and was the only member of
the team to catch any official
competition earlier this year a
competition that relied on physical
strength elsewhere in gender identity
Madness controversial male to female
trans cyclist Austin killips won a
competition in the US this week by five
minutes throttling a biologically female
challenges in a grueling 137 mile race a
question of defining men and women to
extend a stage in Parliament today at a
major debate in Westminster Hall MPS
have been debating the legal definition
of sex after a petition signed by 110
000 people the position started by the
sex matters campaign asked the
government to change the equality act
make it clear that in UK law sex means
biological sex and not sex Modified by a
gender recognition certificate they said
based on about transphobia but about
assuring women about their right safety
and fairness well I'm by the founder of
sex matters Maya fostata and labor MP
and women's rights campaigner Rosie
Duffield was just taking part in the
debate so Rose let me start with you
you've just taken part in this debate
how did it go is common sense prevailing
I think so peers it felt like it there
were far more speakers who wanted the
equality act clarified than there
weren't on the other side who thought it
should just be left as it is
I mean the thing is ma you've obviously
been involved in this today as well
you read the story about the England
female Anglers team that half of them
have felt the need to resign because a
biological male now a trans woman has
come in and has obvious physical
Advantage which allows that person to
beat biological females this is it's as
clear as night and day how unfair this
is
do you feel you're winning this battle
to to have this kind of thing recognized
as wrong yes I think we're winning the
battle
um both because Sports women like the
the Anglers are taking a stand that's
really important but they shouldn't have
to do that the law should be clear it's
the law that allows you to have uh all
women's sports because that's fair and
individual sports women shouldn't have
to uh you know give up their career or
worry about their career
um just for standing up for what's fair
so we had the MPS in Parliament today
talking about the equality act which is
ultimately what protects all sports uh
Single Sex Services uh hospitals women's
refuges everywhere where you can say no
men allowed here is governed by the
equality act and to have the MPS focus
on women's rights and say uh they're
willing to talk about what the
definition of sex is and potentially
clarifying it in the law which would
then mean that these women like the
Anglers don't have to put themselves on
the line I mean Rosie Rosie both you and
Maya have both been abused vilified
shamed branded transphobic and so on
simply for in my estimation standing up
to protect women's rights you must have
felt quite lonely at times this battle
do you feel like yes more women are now
joining the calls in particular
yeah it did feel this time that the
debate was more balanced kind of on us I
have like you said often felt like I'm
the only voice especially on the labor
side and that's pretty emotionally
exhausting when all I read about myself
is defamation and lies and names and
it's it's yeah it's not fun all the time
Maya for you too I mean it's it's a
brutal business poking your head over
the parabit to debate this isn't it
absolutely I I lost my job for it I was
I was working a think tank where you'd
think you'd be able to think about
things
um and I lost well you can if you think
the right way well exactly exactly
um and it's been a four-year legal
battle just to get Justice for losing my
job
um so yes it's been it's been tough but
there there were so many women in the
chamber watching today I think the MPS I
feel I feel on this issue that the woke
worm is turning I feel like common sense
is beginning to Prevail that there's a
really concerted fight back now from
people saying yes it's fine to respect
trans rights to fairness and equality I
completely sign up to that but the
moment it starts to erode women's rights
to fairness inequality and safety that's
where I have a problem absolutely and I
four years ago you weren't able to say
that four years ago it was only about
trans rights whereas now we're able to
say this is about fairness it's about
quality it's about dignity and privacy
and everyday Services
um and it and it's about being able to
speak the truth everyone knows what sex
people are
um and what sex they they are uh and
shouldn't have to lie about that in
order to keep their job well Rosie uh I
think kirstan was now up to saying that
99 point something percent of women
don't have a penis I think as his latest
stat are you confident we may get him to
100 percent
that would be really good because no
woman I've ever met no biological woman
has a penis I mean that's pretty much
the definition isn't it of a biological
male and what's important we joke about
it but what's important is that rape is
obviously
um an offense caused by mostly male
penises so we do need to be absolutely
clear and signal to women that we
understand the importance of language
are you being welcomed by more of your
party now are you still a pariah foreign
I'm definitely still a pariah I'm afraid
I mean there are societies within labor
like the LGBT labor group and people
like that who absolutely hate me and
won't stop until they've got my scalp on
a pole and uh you know as the party
edging in the right direction I hope
that they won't leave me behind
um and decide that you know I'm an
unfair game but you never know politics
is a dirty business well we've got your
back on Piers Morgan uncensored Rosie
and you keep fighting and Maya the same
with you this is a this is Battle has to
be won it's a battle for common sense
and for Kia starma and for others who
have a problem about this you're the
problem and need to sort yourselves out
the number of women with penises is zero
it's not difficult this it's actually
quite straightforward so let's all get
with the program of Common Sense
that's it from us tonight whatever
you're up to thank you to both of you to
Myron to Rosie that's up uh all for us
tonight Keep It Uncensored the night
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign